su nombre es abdalá la vacuna contra el
cob y 19 desarrollada en suelo cubano
origen de gran orgullo nacional con ella
cuba se une al puñado de poderosos
países que han desarrollado su propio
suero su productor afirma que la vacuna
de 3 dosis ha arrojado un 92 por ciento
de efectividad en la tercera fase de
ensayos apenas 10 meses después de
iniciar los proyectos en un laboratorio
el cgp y el instituto filial de vacuna
se alcanzan los datos de eficacia como
bien decías en un escenario
epidemiológico complejo durante el fin
de semana otro laboratorio cubano
anunció que su vacuna llamada soberana 2
tiene una efectividad del 62 por ciento
usando dos de las tres dosis en las
próximas semanas se espera que ambas
vacunas reciban luz verde de las
autoridades cubanas si bien el país ya
ha iniciado la campaña de vacunación
temiendo el avance del virus
por eso ahora la gente ha bajado mucho
más la cantidad de contagios aquí en la
habana
cuba intentará vacunar a al menos el 70
por ciento de la población para agosto
el presidente cubano ha aclamado ambas
noticias como una victoria científica y
política bajo un embargo estadounidense
desde 1962 cuba ha desarrollado una
robusta industria farmacéutica y de
biotecnología presumiendo de una larga
historia de producción de vacunas